I left Union when I was 21 and if you're
then coming out right I've got to put
the work in to get there no one's going
to give it to me if you want to be
successful at something you have to work
hard you have to be prepared to do it
expect to be a spam for knowledge you're
not going to know especially at 21.
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Seb who's the
managing director and owner of river Rec
recruitment you've been in the industry
for over 10 years so first year Revenue
was around 175 000 pounds second year
the revenue was around 290 third year
350 most recent year 1.4 million now in
this conversation Seb is a super honest
and authentic guy and when you go into
detail the challenges in growing this
business but most of all how he's really
approaching scaling his company the
infrastructure that he's going to have
to invest in to help it continue to
scale without breaking the leadership
team that he's going to have to develop
and we go into scaling and growing a
recruitment company it's entirely
self-funded what do you believe are the
characteristics and traits that make up
a highly successful creature in today's
market
um well I can go on the best for the eye
of the scene and I would use the word
enjoy this week's episode let's get into
it Sam welcome to the podcast thank you
very much thanks for making the trip
it's all right it's good uh enjoy your
content
you strike me as someone that's uh you
know not afraid to share your opinion
and I've uh I always respect that
particularly in today's world and I also
put on here which I'm going to speak to
you about I feel like you are like the
king of poles
like you put out a lot of polls on
LinkedIn I do like putting out polls
yeah they get good engagement though and
then it seems to be as if people then
see my other posts yeah it's probably
more serious so I've got a question
around polls I just when I think of like
when I said go on your profile and look
at this I was like you're just always
asking interesting questions yeah with
polls which I find uh really interesting
but so we're here to talk about your
entrepreneurial Journey
um which over the last five years you've
been building your own recruitment
business so yeah I know you've been in
the industry for over 10 years
um so I just want to give everyone some
immediate context and then we'll we'll
get into this and unpack this
entrepreneurial Journey that you you've
been on so feel free to correct me if
I've got any of this wrong but started
your business reverek uh in May 2018
um some of the key sort of highlights of
Milestones here so uh first year was
just yourself so uh yeah first year
reduce yourself so first year Revenue
was around 175 000 pounds second year
there was about three of you um was
around 290 third year 350 free people uh
fourth year 780 and fifth year most
recent year 1.4 million and you're
operating around uh you showed me 20 to
30 profit and it's about 18 officially
uh of you and you have big aspirations
to get up to 40 people now yeah have no
intention of selling this business
and you're really excited about some
recent markets like Germany East Coast
um so yeah there's some of the
highlights yeah yeah that's correct cool
so let's start with a million pound
question which is and and I think I know
I always say this but
you know understanding your hiring model
which uh from what I understand is you
know recruiters that have experience uh
oftentimes
um
like what what do you believe are the
characteristics and traits that make up
a highly successful recruiter in today's
market so
um well I can go on the best people that
I've ever seen and I would use the word
obsessive they're kind of really
obsessed with the detail of what they're
doing and it's not just the process of
what they're doing it's they have to be
the best so every aspect if there's
someone set a new level in they still
have to beat them it doesn't matter what
it is they're just obsessive about all
the detail of what they need to do to be
the best but that's the a grade biller
so they know they have the knowledge
they've got all of that but it's in the
desire
based on their Obsession to be the best
and that's they're the best people I've
ever seen um
so how how do you try and find that and
see that in a interview process
the reality is it's really difficult um
I think the challenge for us is when we
kind of started
because I was on my own
I didn't really want to take in people
that were quite Junior and train them up
because then if I'm the main biller and
I'm going to train someone at the same
time
it's then really difficult and obviously
we have trainees the reality of it is
there is a high turnover they may not
work out so we looked for people that
have relatively experienced when we
started
we've moved probably in the last
kind of nine months I plan for you know
moving forward is to look at graduates
and people that are probably second
jobbers who want to come into
recruitment because I think if you're
looking at experienced people only
that's really difficult
um but trying to find people are
obsessive who are brilliant if I'm being
honest with you really really difficult
you have them all look at
they've got the certain traits about
them I.E they really want to be the best
they've got a desire there but perhaps
where they've been they haven't
had that nurtured or developed and you
can see they're Keen they're
enthusiastic but maybe the company
they've been at has held them back they
have a desire their reason for leaving
is because they want to be better than
where they are they've got a need to go
and do it and that's the best that you
can probably look for looking at the
potential rather than the finished
article because as a smaller
startup business I think the reality is
it's really difficult to be able to just
go I want a grade billers let's go and
get a grade billers in unless you've got
a massive cash pool of money and we're
self-financed so the reality is you have
to have some form of compromising you
have to therefore look at the potential
rather than look at the finished
articles
how I know you shared with me that you
always had intentions to grow this
business yeah
how if that was your intention how
difficult was that first year or being
on your own
um
it was difficult but not
for the reason I expected to be honest
actually
I thought the difficult part would be
because I had a restrictive covenant
and I was a regional manager on the left
I bite strictly I didn't go out and just
start working with clients or try and
push my luck I had to build a new desk
my initial kind of thinking was this
could be really difficult and I backed
myself as a very good BD person that was
always my strength
um but I didn't
I didn't think it would probably be I
thought that would be the hardest bit
getting the BD on the actual part that I
found really hard and why I've got a lot
of respect for people that work from
home I found it really difficult being
on my own in the spare bedroom in my
house
you know people go oh it's great I love
it within three weeks I'm talking to
myself in there I just go and climbing
the walls so if anything I use that as a
desire to go right I have to definitely
get an office this is the goal this is
what I want to do so I knew I want to do
that anyway but that was the hardest bit
the kind of isolation the loneliness
because you want to build something and
you've got ideas
and you want other people on board and
it was more or less that year was trying
to get the cash flow together to kind of
then go right let's bring some people in
hire two free people bring them on board
and then start going from there
speak to a lot of Founders that that is
their biggest challenge is there
anything that you did to help with that
person speaking to yourself
so in the in the in the room right was
it was your partner really important in
supporting you was it like what what
actually helped you well yeah I mean
I I've
always made an effort to make sure I had
a lot of friends in good positions in
recruitment anyway so
I'll regularly go even now for lunch
with other directors of bigger firms
than we are and I'll sort of bounce
ideas off them I think
some companies and some people are kind
of guarded against doing that having a
chat with different directors because
they think I don't want to give them
ideas but the reality is most people
like that kind of thing so for me A lot
of it was trying to have a chat with
people trying to have an engagement
things like that to bounce ideas off see
where you're going people perhaps who've
been in the same position as I had been
before
I went from there and
um my wife's really supportive she
co-owns a company but she's a bookkeeper
by trade she's not a recruiter she
didn't understand the recruiter side of
it so I was it was basically me doing it
from there and it was fine and she was
supportive and stuff I just think the
the outlet I guess you you want in that
position
um I'm glad to say you you said you've
seen other people in the same spot would
you want a bit of social interaction I
am probably more an extrovert than an
introvert and I think that was probably
the difficult part for me I really
respect that you
in you know it's built relations other
recruiters or recruitment directors as
you said because I'm just a big believer
that one there's enough business out
there for everyone yeah and two I feel
like the more knowledge sharing that we
do this is why we do this this podcast
do as an industry the the better chance
we have of
overall raising the the levels of
service the standards in in our industry
if we're all striving to just continue
to improve be better and deliver better
better service right so how important
have if that was quite important at that
stage have you had had mentors on this
journey have you had people that you
sort of tapped into or lent on or spoke
to it peers in this five-year Journey
has that been quite important
I wouldn't say if I'm being honest I've
had like mentors or I've gone
You're Gonna Be My Mentor to teach me
how to do it
um but I would say I've taken a lot of
advice off people the position I was
kind of in was
I was a man I was I was a regional
manager so I'd done the assistant
manager the team manager the regional
manager and before I even got into
Recruitment and I got in recruitment
fairly late even I was graduate I saw
the 25
before that point I'd been a manager in
Mobile phones so I think I was fairly
comfortable with the kind of management
and the aspects and whenever you're a
manager of something like that you
always there's a bit of a loneliness
anyway because you're on your own you
have to be comfortable with that and I
think I was okay with that but there
wasn't specifically a mentor it's more
or less a sort of Vice asked a lot of
questions same as same as when you're
learning when you want to come up in the
in the in the ranks whatever as a
recruiter you'll ask a lot of questions
so for me it was you've done this before
can I ask a bit of advice and people if
you ask are really happy to help so that
was that was kind of I wouldn't say I
was an individual Mentor no but yeah but
I've got advice when you yeah you're
just curious about certain things
I guess I'd be silly not to ask looking
back like and now tapping into your own
experience because you've
now gone on that Journey you've trodden
the path yeah
what was the best advice that you got
given do you think
the early stages
um
I don't know I guess it was they could
kind of continuously look to improve no
matter where you are
you're always looking to and it was kind
of a belief that I kind of had anyway
that a couple of people have sort of
said to me whatever happens as you go
through it the markets change
industry changes you'll change and
evolve your company's circumstances
will alter as you grow but you're always
looking to to learn but be proactive
about trying to learn so for me off the
back of that
um I read even more so I've got like a
bit crazy and obsessive about sort of
management and leadership books I don't
know why I just love reading all this
kind of stuff I'm just a bit of a sponge
for knowledge but the more you kind of
learn the better you'll be like
knowledge I know it's a bit of a corny
line but knowledge is power so for me I
wanted to know as much as I could I I've
and I think the best advice I've had was
kind of never stop being a student of
the job I love that and I think
recruit is the thing they've completed
recruitment because they build 300 400
whatever the number is that's a mindset
they want I'm sure you try and instill
in people as well right
yeah there's
there's never I don't know there's
always there's always more to do I just
I find it really difficult to kind of um
if you have someone that goes I know it
all
then that's and it's just from from my
end coming up in the ranks and I was I
was probably more obsessed rather than I
was I was never top biller but I was
always one of the top billers but my
main bit was Mr consistent I'm going to
overtake everyone and progress so I
broke the record to get from a trainee
to a regional manager
and that was I wanted to progress I
wanted to meet everyone so my thinking
was anyone around me seems to think that
they know it all their daddy what do I
need to do to know more than them so I
can overtake them and I'm just I don't
know that kind of
competitiveness I think was something
that you I got from from learning
different stuff so yeah yeah no I I just
really like that because when you do go
out on your own you and you've been used
to working in the team you instantly
lose
the ability to learn from the people
around you and learn from other people
so I can understand why that would be
a really you know sound bit of advice I
guess if we could just hone in on on a
certain part of this journey over the
last five years because I think it's
often
when I speak to other recruitment
Founders a really difficult period so I
know you know second year third year
there's around three of you
um is it was it the fourth year fourth
year that you then sort of entered
there's more like 10 of you and and
going yeah we've yeah we probably
expanded a lot more recently I mean the
main problem I guess there was two
problems that we had
which were
we were in a market which was heavily
challenged by covid
so I know a lot of tech recruitment
Founders obviously kovid happened then
all of a sudden boom's great for him we
weren't in we weren't really in Tech
then we sort of only our like our Tech
side of it it's only really started
going over the last kind of nine months
or so it's a newer team my background
and what we built on was kind of energy
engineering and Manufacturing you
imagine going into kovid where I'd
started for the first year 2018 2019
wanted to hire then all of a sudden
March 2020 lockdown yeah no mum's in and
we're doing most of our deaths were
manufacturing they shut all the
factories immediately you've all the
cash you built up to try and hire people
then you're like right I've got to keep
that in the bank you can't go out hiring
people at that moment and we didn't have
the knowledge just to change Market
completely we had to adapt and be quite
flexible at the point and get into
things we probably hadn't done before so
at that point it was probably playing it
fairly safe but then after that point
then we started getting better
understanding the niches that were
looking at the data started hiring in
people from other companies who had
experience of it and started bolting in
things and folded it into what we did in
the stem markets and then I think we've
started accelerating so now we're just
kind of continuously higher in every
sort of
personally I don't know three weeks
probably
um it's summer start this week three
people started sort of a month ago
someone started a month before that so
we just started the real it's been yeah
12 months has been really yeah more
recent yeah
so it seems like one of the the lessons
then was the importance of
diversification then yeah
yeah the irony of it is a lot of people
kind of say
um when you start up it is true you kind
of and I've heard it on your podcast as
well but people said other places it's
mild deep inch wide that's great if you
want to get in the problem is if that
buy a wheat if that mile wide
um a mild deep sort of Niche
um a while deep not kind of Niche um
collapses your eggs are all in one
basket so I think of anything from covid
it was then kind of a wake-up call yes
be an expert in your field but also have
enough Flex as a business that you can
ride when you're in the downtime when
you're in a bit of a difficult period
I've always just go out of business and
I think that you see the statistics on
new companies starting up that fail and
you hear the success stories as well but
most companies fail for a reason or for
a few reasons one of them is that they
were kind of caught in a niche that then
collapsed and then they don't have any
Flex so I do believe you need some Flex
as a business to be able to deal with
the ups and downs of the market
so with that lesson then would you mind
sharing how you've now got it set up
what you said obviously the stem market
so what what does that actually look
like so your bread and butter was
manufacturing yeah so what would be the
typical client at that stage before you
did diversify what was like the typical
type of yeah so we would have had
a lot of Aerospace
um and automotive and stuff like that
um and you would hire what the people
well yeah you'd have so you'd have
maintenance Engineers
um design Engineers
um you might have electrical engineers
mechanical project managers all this
kind of stuff but obviously if they're
working in factories and they just close
the factories down and they're
non-essential the production just stops
they don't need to hire anyone and still
to this day we're mainly perm yeah so
the problem is it's not as if you can
have a contract to run in the background
and the contracts we did have running at
the time they just shut them off as soon
as so it's kind of March 2020 because I
don't need them so that was where we
were in but the setup now is where we
have an engineering team which is a
general engineering team which will do
with the kind of stuff that you would
look at that's necessity okay so stuff
needs to be fixed stuff needs to be
improved there needs to be quality
checks in place for regulations across
manufacturing across engineering that's
a core part of it and that tends to be a
fairly safe predictable conversation
it's essential yeah which was a market
that we wanted to make sure they've got
a safety net so
if you look at it generally depending on
what regardless of what happens in the
market around it you'll still need those
kind of roles filled there'll always be
a demand for them so that's one part of
it the other part we've got is an
advanced engineering kind of thing which
is more someone's coming in they want a
20 000 pound sort of fee roll 30 000
pound feed roll something like that a
real specialist high level engineering
director Project Director that kind of
stuff but in expert in it we will go out
it's much more the kind of I wouldn't
say I wouldn't describe its head hunting
but the kind of roles they're giving us
are going to be a lot harder where you
come in a lot of the volume will be
slightly lower the fees are much higher
and then the other part of it is a tech
team which is broken into at the moment
software data
um and then Germany so we do software
and data in the UK and software and data
in Germany but that's a much smaller
part of what we want but those are good
again a core area of
um of tech that we can then establish
ourselves on it and then bolt on product
and bolt on different areas of it as we
expand so what we've kind of done is got
three separate parts of the business
three different revenue streams if you
like which then balance out a fairly
the tech probably is a little bit harder
on the market at the moment but
certainly from an engineering
perspective that's booming so that's
doing really well so we've got Flex is
the point of it and then do those do
they overlap at all in terms of like the
the tech side are you targets and
manufacturing companies that are you
know implementing certain
I don't know you know the I think when I
spoke to some engineering recruiters
like you have these like robots in
manufacturing digital transformation
stuff like that so like are you trying
to be intentional around that yeah what
you want to do is you want to kind of
thought you don't want to be right
there's one arm of the business over
there one arm and they're not connected
you want it to be at folds within it so
therefore for some of the accounts we've
got on we've got some big billions or
PLC companies we've also got some smes
but what you'll find is there's a bit of
a pattern in there the multi-billion
companies will have a requirement for
all of the types of roles we can support
them with so therefore that same client
we can get in there and then be able to
land and expand kind of with them by
having a kind of
a lot of crossover on what we cannot are
offering which gives us a lot more
benefit to be able to get in there and
maximize getting on that asset account
if you like with the smes a lot of the
smes that we get on fit within the
supply chain of those businesses so
therefore if you can help one SME within
the supply chain to that end company you
can also help other ones and we end up
kind of using it as folding the
expertise we've got in there to really
maximize the client base that we have
our offering of what we can do for them
and then get a lot of repeat business
out of it as well as trying to BD other
companies in there and that's how we're
kind of scaling that makes sense that's
super super smart and kudos to you to
take in that lesson and really making
sure that you're settled moving forward
so you don't aren't as vulnerable as
yeah as you said right so
just curious on that you said what your
background was how difficult have you
found it to manage people in a market
you've never done
I tell there's two ways you can look at
it I think when I started
I would have not here but when I started
probably
in when I first got sort of a team
manager at my previous company
it was just within the markets that you
dealt with but there were we had
different kind of I would say it's more
generalists rather than verticals but I
wanted the team to kind of have vertical
specialisms within it and the reality of
it is
developing people who then get a
knowledge for a field that you don't
know you can't necessarily give them the
direct advice
so you more or less your measures of
whether they're doing well or not really
come down to are they meeting their
targets are they improving year and year
are the numbers in terms of efficiencies
and productivity is going up and you
have to kind of have kind of a
I'd say more of a pragmatic viewpoint on
it so for example now
I I'll be honest with you I don't know
anything about the data markets directly
but I think if you want to manage a
company and you want to scale your
company if you're limited to I can only
manage people or I'm only confident to
manage people I know the markets are in
you can be really difficult so it's more
about trying to manage people and then
trying to hire in this is what we got in
terms of the people who are in the tech
sector Tech market we've hired the core
ones are very knowledgeable on those
markets there and I have to trust them
so I'm basically trying to hire look
it's not unique to us but when I try to
hire heads of something I'll
deliberately try and get people that
know a lot more about it than I do and
again I'm seeking advice from other
people who are in those markets that are
other directors of other companies that
will give me Fair advice
um to go actually yeah they're credible
they know what they're talking about go
to that person and that person can teach
me things as well otherwise you just
you're never going to scale if I'm only
going to go I'm only going to hire
people that I know what they're talking
about it's really difficult it does
offer a challenge don't get me wrong but
you have to you have to come to a point
where you're like right there is a level
of trust that you have to go in there
and as long as the numbers The
credibility is there and you can you can
formula and understand this person knows
what they're talking about you can you
can kind of work with that but it's much
more people management rather than
teaching them how to do their job
because you don't know what they do as
well as they do yeah
sure I guess what would be helpful for
people if you don't mind sharing so like
I understand that the people management
piece makes complete sense I just said
you've got to trust these people you've
got to really try and get people that
are obviously smarter than you in these
certain areas so would you mind sharing
like what what would those dashboards
look like that give you confidence that
they're on the right track and you know
what are some of the key things that
you're looking at to go right I'm
investing in this person I'm investing
in this data team from what they're
sharing with me they're telling me about
the market at the moment these things
what are the things that you're keeping
close eye on to make you feel confident
that they're going in the right
direction is it are you mainly looking
at the number of new client meetings
they're booking on a quarterly basis is
it the you know the ratios that you're
keeping close eye to what what does like
you know seb's dashboard look like on
the people management side you look at
two factors okay if terms of
I guess kind of inputs if you like one
limits of productivity one of them is
the efficiency okay so you set a
benchmark of where they are in the first
place in terms of what productivities
they have what efficiency they have and
then you've got an initial Benchmark and
then you'll ask other you take advice
from other people in the marketplace
about that particular sector or whatever
what should they be doing what's good
what's bad what billing should they be
doing this kind of thing and again
that's utilizing your network of people
that I kind of know
and then you see that projectory
trajectory trajectory even of where
they're going so you're looking for
productivity increase efficiency
increase that's what you can gauge from
the numbers there but the reality of it
is what you're looking for are they
billing more that that's the outcome
it's actually building more than what
they were are you getting an accurate
return on investment are you in a
position where
you can see it where there's maximize it
they're going in an upward trajectory on
the two areas that you want
and are you in a position where
financially is generating you a profit
to continue to invest in that team and
expand it I know some people kind of
want to look into it more complicated
than that but it's literally you're
looking at productivity inefficiencies
understandable benchmarks you need to
aim for and is it an upward trajectory
that that's that's what I would look at
what would be helpful for people is give
us an example of what would fall under
productivity okay so productivity for us
is more in terms of we would look at the
front end vacancies and probably CV sent
and seeing if it's a good kind of Market
some markets if you're doing more let's
say Advanced engineering you'd be in a
position where you'd expect a lot less
CV sense it's more head hunting because
they're more Niche roles than General
engineering so we'll know the benchmarks
of what you should be selling so if
you're doing an engineering director
you're probably not looking at sending
five CVS in the first week or something
like that but if you're doing a
maintenance engineer we'll know all the
maintenance engineers and all the
companies that require maintenance
engineers in let's say Birmingham would
have mapped out that market you'll know
that you could probably get four or five
across to each that meet the spec that
meet the motivational standards of What
that particular client wants and that
client you know is probably going to go
I want to see at least four of them so
you can go that's a good productivity
there your their productivity is really
what you're looking at in terms of CV
send vacancies but then again if you're
doing
German Ruby Developers for example
that's going to be quite Niche you're
never going to get that many people out
there so you know your benchmarks on
that so really it's against
understanding
what your benchmark should be for
vacancies and CV sent compared to that
market that you're working in that
vertical and then what about efficiency
so efficiencies we measure a few things
that are probably different to a lot of
companies so I'm one of those people who
likes my spreadsheets like geek out on
this kind of stuff so I want to know the
amount of average how much we've covered
in terms of vacancies so we want to
above sort of 50 coverage so for every
vacancy you raise
um you want at least 50 coverage on that
again certain markets you know sorry
what does coverage mean sorry so
coverage if you have two vacancies you
would at least have one of them that you
would get interviews for right so that's
certain jobs which are going to be
that's a general kind of minimum you
might have in engineering okay maybe
it's a new client and you're talking
about averages across the field so if
there's a new client you might have
commitment issues or anything like that
but if it's an experienced client you're
probably looking at about 75 80 coverage
so for every five rolls four of them
you've managed to get past the interview
stage then you're also looking at
efficiencies of how many people you've
got in for each of those interviews
you've got at least two and a half to
three people in for each interview
therefore the client's in a position
where they're going to have they're
going to be satisfied that they've seen
a variety of people and they're more
likely to pick one sooner then you've
got turnaround time in terms of CVS
turnaround time in terms of decisions
turnaround timing in terms of getting
feedback prep work all of these things
if you're really tight on those factors
you maximize your chances of placing and
being really efficient at placing people
and it all comes down to that efficiency
is if you're doing work you're
maximizing certainly from a contingency
recruitment perspective how efficient
you're going to place everything and
obviously as a retainer or if it's
exclusive then you still want to make
sure you deliver on it otherwise you're
going to lose exclusivity or you have to
give back some of the retainer so you
still need to be efficient it's a big
thing that we're kind of obsessive about
I love that oh yeah that's that's why I
asked the question I wanted to know what
was on your spreadsheet
that's what I work with yeah so so just
just to recap on that for people because
this is because look I understand what
you're saying about obviously that
keeping it simple the outcome should be
going in the upward trajectory yeah but
for you to feel confident you know in
terms of the cost that you're adding to
your business and supporting them and
adding um the cost you a business you've
got to see these things on this
spreadsheet going in the arbitrary right
you've got to see those inputs yeah
because you know if they keep going in
the right direction then the outcomes
will come yeah so as you were saying so
from a productivity standpoint and
things like vacancies on number of CVS
out and then efficiency you're saying so
coverage is if I've got two jobs on and
one of those jobs I was able to get one
to three interviews for that's me
covering that job yeah right and then
you're saying then the turnaround time
from interview to what feedback on and
like the turnaround times on those
things yeah you're looking at because
you've got to bear in mind you want to
work with clients that
are willing to work with you a little
bit here if you you'll have certainly
when you do new business development
you'll work with clients where there's a
an issue with commitment let's say you
might have that risk where they'll say
to you all the right things we will want
to see these candidates if you send us
these candidates to me this grade this
motivational match for us
we will see them in X period however
then you often find they don't hold
their word there's problems there's a
commitment issue okay so you have to
have some Flex for that because you have
to go on a bit of a Goodwill word when
you start dealing with repeat clients
obviously the ones that are efficient
then you by working with the client and
they understand that if we meet this
criteria in terms of turnaround time
we've able to deliver this for deliver
this for you this will be the outcome
for you and we'll be nice and efficient
so you're not having clients coming back
to us time and time again going I know
if I ask reverek for this I'll get this
in this period And it's like a
productivity straight what it is it's a
very efficient kind of machine
that is what we're trying to replicate
across our markets and continue so we
can scale makes sense this podcast is
proudly partnered with vincere the
all-in-one recruitment agency software
that over 20 000 recruiters trust daily
we're also partnered with the
award-winning one-up sales sales and
motivation platform that enables you to
maximize the potential of your teams we
love partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to this podcast and get up to 10 of the
usage price forever use a link in the
show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode so a lot
of Founders that I uh speak to in the
recruitment industry can often find the
period from going from 10 to 20 often
quite difficult yeah
so let's just focus on that for a sec
because you're like in the thick of this
right now are there any you know
obstacles barriers that you are finding
yourself run into that maybe you didn't
expect in this you know growth period
what what have you found maybe more
difficult than you anticipated
I don't think there's anything that I
didn't expect the bit The Challenge the
main challenge that's there that all
people all founders will find when they
get to sort of the 10 20 period because
that's the bit where loads of companies
get stuck yeah like you say and the
reality of it is you need some form of
infrastructure in there to scale so for
example yes I've got free teams across
the business but it's all very well same
right gonna hire 10 people for that team
if you've got one manager on that team
managers direct people you can actually
manage the magic number is kind of seven
okay you finally seven seven recruiters
to one manager that's the magic number I
don't know it's not just it's not just
in recruitment it tends to be across the
park what you want is if it's more than
that can you manage more like yes you
can how efficient are you going to be at
doing that how much time you're no
matter give them that the efficiencies
start to get damaged after that before
that you're not maximizing what you can
get so that's the magic number that that
I found that works but it's not unique
to recruitment there are many books
written in different Industries and
industries yeah the seven just to be
clear seven to one because I think
that's an interesting Insight we found
when we surveyed our customers yeah it
was around like between five and seven
was the typical average number of
recruiters the one manager yeah and just
to be clear you viewing that as those
managers also contribute also have a
number and also billing as well as
manage it being like player coaches yeah
so the structure we've got and what
we're working towards is with those
managers they are developing up to seven
people themselves with the idea and my
role is I'm hands off so my role is to
try and be on the business to go in and
try and develop the managers that meet
the criteria of being able to build but
also meet the criteria of being able to
be accountable for certain areas of
management in terms of behaviors with
the idea B and we develop a second line
of management so we've got two other
guys coming on our most our longest
serving team is the general engineering
team they should be coming through
before the end of the year main manager
two sub managers you build teams under
them you get a team of 21 we develop
within that another manager and that's
how you manage to scale okay and go back
to your earlier question what's the
challenge that a lot of companies come
between 10 to 20 is the infrastructure
is the is the challenge realistically if
you can get people that are effective
managers that you can trust you can
delegate to and you have them time after
time you can escalate it and the senior
manager on that team that's how you get
them to be able to be a hands-off
director so yes they're Hands-On
Hands-On billing managers now but the
Viewpoint and the structure is when you
end up getting to the this their role
moves more to people management may I
then move back more to a macro level
opening up other offices or whatever and
you've got an operation that
theoretically I don't even need to be
involved in that manages itself and
grows itself because you have that
infrastructure but the main challenge
going back to it between 10 to 20 you're
getting that core infrastructure because
it is hard so let's break this down a
bit because I think this would be useful
so yeah I'm assuming then
the core part of that infrastructure is
the leadership team and having people
that you feel confident that you can put
up to seven people underneath and then
you can grow from there so we've got
leadership
what else are you investing in
infrastructure wise to be ready for this
growth because I think this is where
sometimes a lot of Founders I speak to
um run into challenges I don't know what
you found it sounds like you investing
in it now and getting it already but I
speak to a lot of Founders who think
right when I get to 15 people will worry
about that or like rather like let's
worry about when we get to that whereas
a lot of you know successful recruitment
entrepreneurs I've sat down with it's
like you have to have that
infrastructure in place now to grow into
yeah you can't if you go I'll cross that
bridge when you get there that's where
the problems come in because the larger
a company gets the more difficult it
gets to be able to change the direction
that you're heading in if you're heading
in the wrong direction you know when
there's one of you or two of you you can
pivot pretty quickly yeah pivoting a
larger company saying larger company but
even past 10 people all of those people
you've got to get buy-in from it becomes
difficult so the structure we have is to
try and deliberately set ourselves up
and invest in what we need
before a company that is a 40-person
community so as we scale into it we
don't have to make as many amendments
what you don't want is if you if you
scale them and the the kind of thinking
of we'll change that when it gets to it
you have to make a lot of change loads
of change disrupts things you want to
have it proactively put in place before
it gets there
so your actual change in involvement
just looks linear nobody notices it
because it's a nice smooth process
everything works seems to work out well
if you try and do it all in one go
that's where you have problems yeah I
love it so let's break it down so you've
got leadership part of that what else
are you doing right now or what else are
you
investing in getting ready to be ready
to be a 40 person company we doing
anything we bring your Finance in-house
are you making sure you've got
documented processes for yeah you know
how we do things like what what else so
a lot of it is having the documented
process what we got so we have
we've got we've revised our training
program a lot we spend an awful lot of
time trying to train people so when
someone let's say they're an experienced
recruiter that comes in from another
company even if they're a lot bigger
than us they come in they go oh my God
their training is probably good so we'll
put in a lot of companies just offer
practical training we'll offer psych
training so for example you get a lot of
recruiters that will go quite a bit
difficult doing that or a new market
they really challenge with it we can
teach them through that we deliver our
training based on learning learning
Cycles so audio audio visual kinesthetic
all this kind of stuff so we'll have
documented processes for that as well
but also we're trying now this stage of
where we are is trying to put people in
place that almost we spoke about in a
sort of proofing but to sack myself
at the moment
um
at the moment we I do a lot of the
marketing and don't be wrong I love
doing like I love sitting there and
doing the videos and putting content out
and things like that love the polls but
it's as in then you want to bring in a
marketer and develop that person on it
but again try and bring someone who's
better than I am and then the
administration we've got that function
in there already what does that work so
let me wait sorry sorry just so first
you said site training tell me about
that what do you mean by that so
psychological training what is that so
basically you'll have it where goal
management proper understanding short
medium and long-term goals okay so
you're not just trying Living For The
Moment you're kind of understanding if
you're putting the work in now which is
unpleasant this is why it's worth it
this is what you're working towards okay
um then you'll have kind of the
psychological bits so a lot of trainees
when they come in they come across a
period which we call kind of S2 or
whatever which is where they I don't
know if you ever come across a model
called
um it starts off with like it sounds a
bit strange but uh unconsciously
incompetent if you've ever come across
this term yeah no I didn't recommendous
um what's this unconsciously incompetent
competently uh competent consciously
consciously yeah it's a bit of a it's a
bit of a weird thing yeah so we'll teach
them through that which isn't it's not
unique to recruitment it's just general
kind of Psych stuff that we've built up
either from my own knowledge or that
we've read all the other companies have
implemented to try and build it up so we
can develop those people but
going back because I mean I promise I'd
be it'd be a massive long answer if I
said all of the infrastructure we do on
it but the idea being we have documented
processes and then training and
benchmarks of where people should be so
the idea that when we have Marketing in
place Administration in place sales
teams BD
um look account management we are in a
position where all of those functions
work better than I could manage them
and therefore I could sit there and go
these people are better than me I don't
need to do anything that puts you the
idea isn't to sell but if you're an
investor that's what you want to see
you've got to do anything but that means
it's also a very work very well run
slick ship that's what we're working
towards okay love that so we've got the
um leadership team the training which is
absolutely crucial so and also your
um processes documenting how you do
things benchmarks where people should be
these things you've got
um as you said the the marketing piece
yeah
talking about admin like what does that
mean like are we talking about someone
that's always cleaning your your
database are you talking about people
that what does that look like in terms
of admin well the administrator
administrative stuff we always have one
of our philosophies is is kind of
simplify
so if you make loads of admin
Administration and paperwork or anything
like that can get really really
complicated so you've got we work it out
as and if you've got gdpr compliance
checks and I'll oversee the compliance
checks and administration will then do
the compliance checks we can make sure
we've got a double kind of red flag in
place to make sure we're doing data
cleansing or anything like that but in
terms of actual set processes
we will have set process in terms of for
example
let's say we're sending
um invoices out
a lot of companies that I SP you know I
speak to that are small enough or people
have reached out to me and go could I
have some advice on because we struggle
to get paid we will have it and I don't
know why most companies don't do this
we'll have it where if we've placed some
with a company we'll have our
Administration team send out by the way
we just placed someone with you can you
give us whether we need to fill in a uh
any forms or anything to have us on
board if you're a new client the invoice
is going to be on this date is for this
person this is it do we need to complete
anything beforehand
therefore when it comes to the date
they're expecting the invoice you've got
the invoice out this is the payment days
then you've got your set reminders in
place and it's just it's just a set
process and we generally get most of our
stuff paid on time we don't have a lot
of issues that's a big problem that a
lot of recruitment companies had and to
be honest it's probably something we've
refined a lot over the last 18 months
two years because we did have that issue
in the pandemic and we didn't want to
get back in that position again
okay really interesting so just on that
because you said a lot of people reach
out and then I just want to ask you how
you see this business looking and
structured at 40 people because I think
that would be interesting in terms of
how you sit with those different parts
um but where where do like how on
average how long does it take to get
paid then right now so for us we
generally do 14 days so most of the
reality is most clients will pay about a
week like a week so on average people
depending around 20 days yeah probably
people pay about 20 days we'll do 14
days for standard a lot of companies
will say to us look we need to do 30
days not a problem okay so that's
generally but I would say the average
for us from someone starting to us
getting paid is 20 days why do people go
wrong then if you've had a lot of these
conversations one they don't have even
any sort of process they're just sort of
like oh we've played someone in seb's
company so let's chase up hey so you now
need to pay as an invoice I'll put a
calendar invite in there for a week if I
didn't hear anything then I'll call got
it yeah so what you've done is you've
built like a Cadence base of like when
we play someone we are proactive and
said hey to prevent any sort of you
saying to us well you need to complete
this or you need to do that or you need
to be in our system and saying hey we
play someone amazing what infrastructure
do you have internet that we need to be
on if any for us to get yeah so you've
basically just documented like when
someone gets paid this is what happens
and you've got someone responsible for
that in your business accountable yeah
so just is your advice then if you're
struggling to get paid in 30 days and on
average you're getting paid 90 days
later or 60 days later which is
obviously going to impact your cash flow
yeah it's like make sure that whoever it
is in your business is one person that
falls under responsibilities and you
document how we Chase to get paid yeah
that's that's the key thing what happens
is your question was kind of what advice
would you give like as in what's the
typical mistake that people make what a
lot of recruiters do is when they start
a company
um they kind of go like recruit really
well I'll be able to go and you know if
you have to I can do this myself the
reality of running a business there's
books written on this as well
there's three pillars you kind of have
to look after one of them is the task
are you being a good recruiter one of
them is they say operations which is
that kind of stuff to make sure
everything's done and one is the vision
of the platform of where you're going
how you're going to build it so you know
what to meet each grade but the
operational part is the bit where a lot
of companies really fail on because if
you end up behind if you're not with
cash flow if you've got no money you're
in trouble and if you're unorganized it
becomes really really stressful really
quickly you don't want to be in that
position so the bit of advice that I
would give is make sure you're really
tight on your day-to-day operations and
set it up again as if it's if you had 20
people and you have to look at it right
I need to get paid what infrastructure
do you put in place and what process do
you put in place so you make sure you
get paid because if you don't you could
be out of business yeah so let's just
wrap this part up then so reverse you
get to 40 people how do you see like
what's the org chart because I think
that'd be helpful and this sort of ties
it all together so how do you see that
from a leadership standpoint from the
admin Department from the marketing
department what all structure are you
working toward wasn't when that's a 40
person company so the simple bit of it
for me if we kept it as the kind of
three divisions we've got now the free
resource free um revenue streams if you
like you've got a senior level of
management you've got a second line of
management that gives you the growth
structure you need for the people how
many sales people do you reckon if
you're at 40. well if you're looking at
that apart from the main manager maybe
if they're coming slightly hands off
they're a larger team but they've got 20
people or so you might go okay they'll
spend only a minimal amount of their
time maybe key accounts but generally
speaking all of the all of the people
who
um are on those teams will be
effectively billing apart from maybe
you'll have you know if a key role
certainly on our advanced stuff RIT you
might have resource or non-bank okay
non-staff so I think it's probably
easier way of doing it
um myself my wife who does the his
bookkeeping then the admin teams
probably a couple of those people two
free at that at that size be
just be looking at Administration okay
you're looking at Administration I want
to show if you'd be like ops manager or
anything you can you can give job titles
you might have the operational side of
it in terms of an operations manager or
something like that I would
I don't think even at 40 people you
necessarily need someone who's just
going right you just do operations
management if you've got the right
infrastructure in there you have a lot
of it can operate itself through either
the admin team the marketing team yeah
um the the you know me a director in
terms of although I really don't really
want to be doing any operating that's
danger if you if I'm operating a
business rather than overseeing it
that's how you can get caught yeah so
yeah so two free people haven't seen so
yeah two free people admin team
um You probably have one or two people
well one person marketed or whatever who
can head up that bit you'd probably be
looking at an internal recruiter two or
three directors one probably sales
focused one probably more Ops focused
one General overview and everything
which would be me no trainer what l d
yeah I like training I do want I do want
to and then sorry sorry so then what
would your role look like because like
you said I love the way that you're
because I think a lot of Founders don't
think like the way that you're thinking
right you're very mindful of if I sit
down you know why would you not try and
build a business that you're clear that
you know I don't really have any
intention of selling it but while I'm
not building a business that if I were
to if someone wants to knock on my door
and said hey Seb like would you ever
consider you know someone buying your
business yes why would you not build a
business where you can go and I mean go
yeah so uh if I was to leave this
business this is how it would work this
is my leadership team
etc etc so what would your role look
like because that might that would be
quite a nice thing to add as well so I
kind of
it'll probably be I think you could do
you could probably do it at 50 or
whatever and going back to the L D part
I I would want an internal l d but it
wouldn't I mapped it out a while back in
terms of what you want it'll probably be
more slightly larger I don't think
you might need it but I'd probably get a
good external sort of trainer or
something like that kind of stuff
um going back to your question in terms
of if someone's sort of knocked it was
that the kind of bit well so like so you
you mapped out what the company might
look like so then what would you what
would be the high leverage activities
that you would be doing because because
like you said like so what would you
would deposit once you get to kind of 40
or 50 my main focus would need to be
focused on the big ticket things that
can impact the business developing the
senior leadership team yeah so they can
replace me basically that's your key
part of it
um so the areas that they don't know
that they're weakest on either that I
can develop them on or I can go
externally to be able to offer that
development on that part of it working a
lot with the management team and working
probably to support people with big
ticket accounts so I know probably my
best strength in the business in an
active role is probably trying to win
business I've always been good at
winning business that's probably what
I'm what I'd be best in however I know
if it's if I'm the only salesperson that
would be a problem yeah so I'll be
developing people to be effective at
that but what what I'm really working
towards going back to my earlier point
I'm you try to build an infrastructure
to sack yourself so effectively at that
point you're on the business and then
looking at like a helicopter Viewpoint
what is probably best and it will
probably be at that point more a
strategic role
right let's look at opening up a
separate division what infrastructure
would need for that division to start
that or we go into
let's have a look at the investment arm
we want to go and buy a smaller company
one of those Founders who's got 10
person outfit that we know runs well but
probably is missing the infrastructure
that we need right now let's get our
management team fold them into what
we're doing and then come under there so
it'll probably be more at that point
really my role working towards it to be
strategic non-operational business
business operator itself strategic to
see about uh growth of the The Wider
business
love it you've clearly read a lot we all
read well not everyone reads but like
you know we consume a lot of information
there's only normally a couple of books
that you read that really have an impact
what have been the books that have had
the real impact on you because clearly
you you know love delving into things
any one two books that really stand out
with this particular type of you know
with this type of thing being of
Interest I want to grow my business I
want to make myself redundant I want to
grow my business in the right way any
any books that have had a big impact on
you there's a few there's I've read I
don't know my bookshelf's like hundreds
and hundreds of books but I'd probably
go through ones that come to mind want
to be good to great
um which is the the most ins that's the
first sort of I've read it when I was
like 23 I think I was I just got my
first management job as a assistant
manager in Mobile phones and the branch
manager said to me read that and I just
that was well I get this right
um and then after that
um a book that I guess would be what uh
say the e-myth Revisited which is yes
unreal that's the one which is that goes
through the you need the operations yeah
you need the different hats
um lean the lean star it's pretty good
that's more recent that's pretty good
that's that's very much like build
things that customers want rather than
yeah it's about minimum viable products
what it talks about it's more product
but in terms of I know it's like
California kind of tea I can take
principles from that the principles are
really good so yeah I'd say the ones
that come to mind probably those three I
mean I could list loads but yeah but I
just thought it's interesting because
you've spoke a lot about yeah you know
reading these things so uh as we come to
towards the end here then you said one
of your strengths uh is BD what what are
the sort of principles that you
um really live by when it comes to being
world-class at BD
it's sounds really strange but make him
your friend and then your business
partner
sounds really strange a lot of people
the bit that I when people first get
into sales
the first thing to try to do is sell to
people doesn't work doesn't work nobody
wants to be sold to do they so if you
can make someone like you and they
realize as a person there then the next
thing you know they're kind of doing you
a favor I mean I'm very I'm probably
good at just relationship building and
really if you want to get anywhere and
if you want to do a quick sale like when
it was mobile phones for example it was
transactional transactional if you want
to actually do if you transactional
recruitment are dangerous because you
can be up and down what you want to do
is try and build relationships with
people where they come to you because
they like you you'll have it where you
don't want to be like this but you will
have it let's say you do some new BD
right and you'd finally win them
whatever agencies to work with oh this
other agency okay how how do you get on
with them how many roles I don't really
feel anything but our HR Director really
likes me so keep going back to me
they'll never feel anything just because
they've got a relationship if you could
have that relationship and you can
deliver stuff that's it so for me a lot
of it is you can have a chat with them
find common ground and I'm probably
someone who's
fairly good at finding common ground and
interest with different people from
different walks of life
um and I think that for me I've always
found pretty pretty good in terms of it
and that's the base Market I would say
you know looking at it if you can make
them like you and they can have a chat
with you and then they relax and they
realize you're okay then you start
making the ground and putting in the
groundwork for it but as long as it's
got a mutual benefit I mean ultimately
business is mutual benefit
is it exchange of goods and services
whatever but it's you want to work
together because you like working with
one another you just like each other
that kind of stuff and that's how I look
at sales PD
so I said
I wanted to ask you about uh your polls
okay this might be a hard one most
interesting poll that had the most
surprising result
I don't even know
um
I do them because I don't know the polls
I like the most there's none that stand
out specifically the polls I like the
most are the ones which someone asks a
question which you know if you made you
know someone does like a LinkedIn Post
Yeah and then it's really controversial
and then it's right I'm nailing my
colors to this flag Bowl this is how I
feel about it and then it'll just try
and be divisive for divisive sake I
never quite feel comfortable with that
because then it could bring company and
distribute make me look bad and I don't
I don't feel comfortable doing that even
if you've got certain opinions on
certain things you kind of look at it
and go you want to be reasonable you
don't want to be interpreted the wrong
way the beauty of a pole is you can put
a poll out asking that question and
people then are able to answer honestly
an anonymous lease you actually get a
thing of it there's no poll that I can't
even remember what part worked out
yesterday okay I just thought I'd ask
yeah I can't put it outside yeah
why didn't we I really liked I think I
obviously we've exchanged a few messages
anyway but
really like your honest advice for
graduates we're getting into that part
of the year now yeah and if anyone to
leave people with that because I think a
lot of people resonated with with what
you said yes
I saw it I was like mate obviously it's
overdue us you know sitting down
um doing a podcast like we spoke before
Henry um because you know you said a
Korean recruitment will test you
mentally if you want to be good at work
in the office when you're learning
nobody as you're living the crew will
have highs and lows
like why why why what made you share all
that are you seeing the opposite of
these things when you're sitting down
with people
I guess I'm speaking for my own
perspective of where I would have been
you know the things where people go
message to your 21 year old self or
whatever yeah I left Union when I was
21. so that's how I would look at it
when you come out of uni kind of I've
got a degree
I'm gonna make it whatever and it is
literally the cold hard reality of of
the the Working World or if you want to
be successful at something you have to
work hard you have to be prepared to do
it but if you wanted one kind of advice
that I would look at is
a career and I kind of I think you put
this out yesterday
um start with the end in mind so where
is it you want to be like long-term goal
or whatever if you think of that and if
you're then coming out right I've got to
put the work in to get there no one's
going to give it to me and this is
aiming Recruitment and you do you do
have different people I'm not a big goer
on this kind of just because it's a
generational thing I just look at it as
in a personal personality thing you all
have people that will learn the express
things they'll expect things and they
learn how to learn the hard way rather
than right this is how it works you kind
of you've got to go out there and put
yourself out there expect to be a spam
for knowledge you're not going to know
especially at 21 not 41 not a 51
whatever so go out there and do what you
need to do with the end in mind of what
what it where it is you want to go
that's the advice I would give start
with the end in mind
Seb thank you thank you very much